Now that you're familiar with Direct,
it's time for you to get involved.
Later on we'll learn about
personal health records.
For now,
I want you to go to HealthVault.com,
the free public personal health record
from Microsoft and create an account.
Later on, I'll ask you to use that
account in some other activities, but
for now create it by putting in
your demographic information and
you'll be given a direct email address.
Click on the question mark next
to it and produce a letter for
your doctor explaining
how they can use it.
The letter will refer to the CCDA, CCD,
and CCR, three alternate formats for
an electronic patients summary an EMR
can produce is part of meaningful use.
You'll learn about
them in lesson five B.
Submit that letter for
credit for this activity.